hey is there a costume cooler than mine
is that yeah yeah i didn't have that bit
on my costume i get that
oh i'd like to fly
[Music]
time travel is that a superpower i'd
love to go back and fix some of these
mistakes i've made
i think they have
such a different
outlook on the world there's something
about opposites that attract i think
there's something in icarus that cersei
is just drawn to there's something about
the way that cersei sees the world that
icarus is drawn to i think they balance
each other beautifully between the kind
of practicality and the juicy and honor
sense that icarus has balance between
cersei's way that she sees beauty in the
world and i think that's what keeps them
kind of learning from each other
[Music]
god i hate emojis i know you're
the uh smiley face
well you're going really generic on that
one i don't know any other ones the
sunglasses emoji probably and the the
sparkle emoji to represent her powers
for me it would be i think the guy with
the with the stars in his eyes
like a hand going one like number one
the rocket
the purple ball
where you can talk to the beyond because
i talk to the celestials maybe the hands
because she heals with her hands
well they you know they came quite
with a blank canvas you know and it's
really seven thousand views us
influencing them so who they are says a
lot about who we are so in casting these
10 incredible individuals i find unique
individuals and hoping they would open
themselves up and give us a sense of who
they are so we could shape the character
around who they really are in real life
well i thought that the
this was supposed to be the great female
warrior um should fight like a female
and should have all the grace and
femininity and that her strength should
come from that ballet is very
challenging so i wanted to set myself
that challenge and
hard for me because i'm
a bit impatient
i think the most excited one it's my
husband when i met him
i was already like 38 39 and he said oh
i want you to be an action hero why
don't you do a movie superhero and i'm
like baby forget about it that's never
gonna happen and it did and it's like
see i told you like nothing
and i said it's a big deal this is very
meaningful
i think the time and place that would
have been my favorite because the music
was best and it was
just a really
cool period of time in a cool place was
probably london in the 1960s i would
live in the medieval times if i were
able to be like a princess or something
i think that would be it's fair enough
yeah i think i'm gonna go to ancient
china see my ancestors uh that would be
fun i gotta say 5 000 years ago because
not too much things to worry about or
you know when things were kind of raw
and human there wasn't as much
technology
surreal i mean
yeah i remember seeing you for the first
time looking down
yeah i think it was really cool but
everyone was also kind of scoping each
other out of like hey is there a costume
cooler than mine is that you know i
didn't have that bit on my costume
why have you got this spec can i get
that so it was really exciting and funny
but the costumes we kind of built over a
long period of time into what's best for
the character and also what's going to
be practical for shooting they're not
just a oh let's put on this because it
looks cool it's like okay well how does
that one interact with your specific
superpowers
i honestly love doing the action
sequences i found it very challenging
but i've never gotten the opportunity to
do action like that before
uh and so i just honestly while shooting
it was those parts were challenging
watching it on screen how well it came
together that was my favorite part
[Music]
foreign